e
ready
go well good morning everybody I think
I trust everybody had a good summer
break if that's what you want to call
it um it was down here this week already
several times um so what we have today
on our docket is we're looking at the
306 administrative rules this is the
legislative uh committee for oversight
on Improvement and
assessment and we've been dealing with
the 306 rules here now for a good while
and so as the State Board of Education
and so what we have in front of us today
is we have a the final proposal on the
first portion of the 306s which was
presented to the state board and acted
upon was it last week yeah last week
yeah so what I'd like to do is today
take a look at that uh we are tasked as
the uh oversight committee for
improvement and assessment to be looking
at the academic
standards uh that are are are set for
our state and to look at it in terms of
um through the 306s here to look at
those portions which are really
reflective of those academic standards I
want to also bring to everybody's
attention that we did pass a bill this
year which was one which looked at the
curriculum Frameworks that was 1107
1107 and that requires the department
education to uh maintain the the the
Frameworks because we had taken
Frameworks out of Law and we put them
back in and the Frameworks as they were
amended here will will reflect and do
reflect the academic standards which we
have for education those academic
standards are to be part of the
curriculum Frameworks and that was to
provide the school districts out in the
field the opportunity to really be able
to access and and find them where they
really belong in those Frameworks so
with that I'd like to open up this
meeting right here and we'll we'll look
at the 306 is the first portion of that
uh the August 14 version if there were
some amending language done to that at
the State Board that you tweaked it and
places I don't have a copy of that so
maybe if folks from the education
department that are
here could let us know that yes um
representative lab reached out to me for
a copy and what I sent was the post that
included all the
am okay so that's what we have right
here in front of us
then
okay so then with that I'd like to open
the the the meeting up to discussing
that proposal that was approved by the
state board uh last week and so let's
take a look and and the first part has
some uh information regarding the
information that the department received
from the public and lists the citizens
who submitted public testimony there's
two or three three pages of it and and
then we will start with our discussion
here on page one
and as those on the study committee here
um on page one where we're primarily
dealing with
definitions and as I recall in our last
June meeting we looked at definitions
and we as a committee indicated that
we'd like to see definitions that
reflect statutory language rather than
having it and that I believe has all
been tweaked and all changed within here
so let's let's walk through it right now
anything on page
concern so Mr chair just to be just to
be clear we're talking about um
comments public comment correct no I I
was looking right at the the document
itself oh okay pass the public comment
sorry yeah the on of the final proposal
we're looking at page one not the front
that had all other there thank you yeah
[Applause]
as you may recall we had the discussion
about competencies the definition
competencies and now this this uh final
proposal or version references RSA 193 H
col 1 and and Roman 2 so that is the
there any other you
know concerns that the committee may
have referencing the academic standards
as as they relate to these minimum
standards of public school
approval on on that
page okay and also the definition for
academic standards is that which is in
hang on yeah thanks so so
on on on page one where we've got
achievement of competencies which is an
area that I think we had some concern
back on June
27th
um it's now been added through a
collection of
in terms of the academic standards terms
of achievement of competencies in B on
the the the last the last um you know
the third to the last paragraph So the
definition you'd have to look at 193 H
colon one which is the definition for
competencies which is on the top page
two yeah and achievement of competencies
um collection I'm looking at this is how
the state board has
opted to Define achievement of
competencies um we're not defining
competencies they're saying how do we
get to that
point through a collection of evidence I
would assume that's you know you know
could be very objective evidence it
could be subjective evidence
find evidence yeah yeah just collection
of evidence I mean because we talk about
other things in
assessment are are they things that are
assessed well you know my when we've
talked about this in the past about our
Statewide assessment from the field
teachers are saying there's lots of
different ways of identifying assessment
other than the Statewide assessment
necessarily and takes a lot of time out
of teaching in in our classroom but we
know there and it's formative there's
diagnostic you know you know
uh assessments well so so so an example
here what I'm what I'm you know suggest
I mean through a collection of evidence
assessments
teachers well it more fortive too as
you're moving through I would say it's
it's a com combination of both and to
I I don't know I don't formative guides
instruction summative is the assessment
isn't that I mean I'm not an expert in
but going see how students are
progressing what we might need to
present differently or or reinforce and
something assessment
refolio
whats right thank you and and the reason
I'm picking on this um Mr chair is
because this this was not in the um the
uh the draft that we reviewed on June
27th so this is new um it it's new
language and I'm I'm not clear on what
that
means is that the responsibility of this
committee you know that that's why I
said at the beginning we're dealing with
academic standards yeah and is this an
academic standard or is this more in
line with how we determine whether the
academic standard is being and I think
that's a I think that's a great question
Mr chair and and and
perhaps rather than going through you
know all you know all these rules and I
and I think we do have a a time limit
today um that or time constraint today
that that identifying which rules bear
on academic standards would be would be
good to understand and um and and I
I sent I circulated this around the
table which I think follows on something
that you had sent out at the last
meeting and so this um you know it it
you know uh defines the the um the
responsibilities of the legislative
oversight committee it defines the
process for rule approval and then it
also defines academic standards and
that's the the third thing on this page
means what a student should know and be
able to do in the course or at each
grade level and so achievement of
competencies means a student has
demonstrated competencies at a
proficient level through a collection of
evidence um does that is that an
academic standard or is that a
non-academic standard uh I think is a is
a is a fair question to put out there
but uh but I think there would be a
reasonable argument to to make that
that that achievement of competencies
means a student has demonstrated
competencies at a proficient level
through a collection of evidence so does
that mean what a student should know and
be able to
do in a course or at each grade
level Welling comp proficient level
right and it's there's a lot of ways to
determine that as a teacher myself I
often times recognized
that the the student
understood that basic uh competency by
doing by actually going out and
functioning whether it's being applying
that skill sure whether it be in music
or or art or or in
mathematics so you know it when I when
we try to nail this down through a
collection of evidence I I that I I I I
interpret that as a
wider window for
determining how uh the achievement and
so would that you know if we put in a
formative and summative that doesn't
even do what I did as a teacher because
I was also looking at you know how they
applied those skills in their in their
career or in their you know
understanding of that specific compy
taught in the fourth
grade no no and listening to a parent
you know yeah kid you know really
progressing okay so so listening to a
parent and saying that you know if a
parent says that the student is
competent in something I I don't know if
that's how how um assessment is defined
in here um I don't know if there's a
reason to to merge assessment through a
collection of evidence which is an
assessment area whether that has bearing
on achievement of competencies because I
think there's a whole section in here
later on assessment look when you go
into our statutes and you're looking at
a Statewide assessment it says
objective uh in there that means it's
talking about something such as a norm
reference test or something of that
nature um but achievement of
competencies in terms of a kid that's in
a Career Technical education center how
do you how do you measure a child a
student that's now able to change a tire
or put a brake pad on which is taught in
in in the CTE Center yeah so can we can
we try find see you know even though I
that this is the the academic standards
are what we identify in 193 e2a right
the those those broad learning areas and
then they're further defined within
hopefully in the future the curriculum
which are in the curriculum Frameworks
so I I'm I have no problem with the way
it's it's worded right there as a
teacher I would love that because
through a collection of evidence it
gives me the latitude um and for every
competence we have and and if you go to
CTE there's a lot of competencies in
every course and program are we going to
have some kind of objected test for
everything so so I I that's not what I'm
saying and I think there there may be a
section in here that applies to CTE
there's certainly a section on page um
uh starting on page 17 that applies to
assessment
um
and and I don't know if if adding that
new language on page two through a
collection of evidence is something that
that bears on the assessment part of
everything or I I I just don't know it
wasn't there in any of the early drafts
and so so so I'm not quite sure what U
what the I mean does the department can
the department comment on the rationale
in the department is here today um
is I think I think it probably
accomplishes what I've been trying to
say up here but is there somebody from
the Department would like to speak to
yeah come on up please you can put three
chairs up there if you have three of you
or
are you just going to put your boss up
okay thank you for the record Frank ad
Commissioner of Education uh Julie Shay
administrative rules coordinator for the
Department of Education and so do you
just want to explain where you believe
this language came from sure um after
the initial proposal was um submitted be
and before or during public comment and
before public comment we met with a
group of stakeholders and who had
changes that they wanted to make to the
proposal so that group of stakeholders
just to be clear so included the
superintendent Association members of
this the um task force and the uh Megan
Tuttle from the Nea and um one of the um
one of the suggested language changes
that came through that was adding
through a collection of evidence to the
achievement of competencies in
Competency Based learning that
collection of evidence is one of the key
factors in determining the achievement
of competencies which can include so
what well and actually so one of the
things in a lot of the definitions when
we were working through those initial
drafts the definitions were more about
process than they were about what the
thing was like so initially the proposal
said achievement of competencies means a
student has demonstrated competencies as
a proficient level that is achievement
of competencies through a collection of
evidence which was requested by the Nea
and uh other and the nhsaa and other
stakeholders in that group is more
processed but we didn't think it harmed
the the definition I think that's
probably why it's
included okay thanks I think that's
that's it's helpful to have these
explanations because this isn't
something that uh that um that we saw on
on June 27th and in fact there wasn't
anybody here from the Department on June
27th to help help us sip through um
through that material so I I appreciate
that very much so then then my a
follow-up question to that if I might
would be does does
that or I guess would would would this
part of the rule be characterized as an
as an academic
standard I think that that would be
difficult to do I would say no okay and
and why is that because it's not an
academic standard it is a definition of
achievement of
competencies okay and and the definition
of an academic standard is in statute
and I it out earlier and that's what
you're referring to is that correct
that's correct if you go to uh 3062 a it
says academic standards means academic
standards has to find in RSA 193 E2
a6b correct thank
you further questions from the committee
we could move I think that's helpful
okay thank you very much you might as
well hang loose there if we have some
other okay let's get on the page two of
I think a lot of this is similar to the
discussion we just
had um curriculum is definitely
something we talked about in the past
and that's of course defined in RSA 193
e2a
6C
um uh Mr chair what is the is the red
underline is that new since the February
15th draft or is that new since
uh yes so the initial proposal um once
that has been um submitted um all of
those changes are accepted and then we
kind of start with a new draft of you
know everything's accepted from the
initial proposal so everything that is
read here has been added since um we
received public comment and all that so
this is all new this reflects public
comment and jail car feedback okay okay
thanks thanks so so um
so not everything in in U let me let me
say it another way some of the things
that that are not in red may still be
changes from existing law I mean
existing
rules yes that could be um could have
been a change in the first draft but
that's since been accepted and it is now
part of this proposal and it's not
considered new text anymore but it could
be different from what's currently in
the rules okay and when you talk about
accepted I'm I'm just I just want to
understand I'm just talking about track
changes like are accepting track Chang
no thank you very
much so yes represent cordelli thank you
um thank you both for uh helping us out
here um my question was in relation to n
where Equity is changed to
Equitable um but then it uh the last
part of it the term also includes Equity
so we're changing Equity to equitable
but also referring to equity so in terms
of this um what do we mean by Equity
yeah so this definition applies to both
Equitable and equity and the reason for
the switch was in one of the places
where this terminology was used um some
garans uh between the state board and
the uh uh jail car attorneys believe
that Equitable was the correct
grammatical construct and not equity and
so they just asked us to reverse those
two definitions um but otherwise no
changes were made in terms of um you
know the content of the definitions
because previously it said equity and it
had that definition and it also means
Equitable and they just asked us to flip
that around because of where the terms
were used so to follow up on that a
little bit uh so some of these changes
when you mentioned Jael car have gone
through let let's say attorney May or
some of the others over there correct we
were working with Christina and mik so
these reflect all of the changes with
you not seeing any other hands for page
two here let's move to on forward is you
know three and four I did not I was
using a yellow marker the other night
and I have nothing yellow on those pages
no Mr chair sorry yeah I'm I'm I still
I'm on page two okay
um and
where on on um on the rule of
30601 applicability
uh down at the uh 3061 C references Ed
rules 30620 and
30621 and um and those I believe
are are those is that curriculum um so
you might not have the right draft then
because that did get changed at the
meeting and it should say 30621 and
30622 which refers to the through eight
um minimum approval standards and then
the graduation
requirements okay so that's not so so
it's supposed to be 21 and 22 correct on
30621 which I think is on page 19 of the
handout kindergarten through grade 8
so I I guess my the same question I have
before um is is 21 and 22 an academic
standard and are are 21 and 22 academic
standards and by incorporation into
30601 does 30601 therefore become an
academic standard yeah so they would not
be considered academic standards so so
306 21 and 22 are not academic standards
that's correct now all right and could
you explain the rationale for that oh
because the definition of academic
standards is RSA 193 E2 A- you know 6B
which I can read the definition if you
don't have it yeah I've got it right
here means what a student should know
and be able to do in a course or at each
grade level right so so
30621 kindergarten through grade eight
School
curriculum so I I'm I'm on that page
page two with your page 19 right at the
base yeah uh the local school board
shall require that in each school there
is an elementary school curriculum and
the curriculum must be aligned with the
academic standards which are reflected
in the curriculum
Frameworks uh maybe it would have been
wiser you know not wiser but you know
helpful uh if we aligned to State
academic standards located in the
curriculum Frameworks that outlines
District competencies and going you know
so making a reference that the
curriculum Frameworks and as I mentioned
at the very start of this meeting that I
I understand the academic standards to
be now located properly in the
Frameworks which are serve as a
guideline for our schools yeah I mean so
you have the academic standards and the
framework is just the vessel in which
those are held
yeah so I'm still trying to understand
why why 21 and 22 are not academic
standards and are not subject to the um
um recommendations these are referencing
course you know course courses basically
um and academic standards means what a
student should know and do and if you
look at those academic standards it
enumerates specifically what a student
should be able to know and do so um
that's the
difference
so you can have academic standards in
one location and curriculum in another
location in the
school and when we look at Improvement
and assessment we're measuring whether
that curriculum is aligned with the
academic standards we know in some
places curriculum is not aligned with
the state
standards uh and so they are separate
that you have curriculum you have
instruction you have assessment and the
and it's the driver of the whole machine
is your academic standard
and so I I I kind of concur here the
elementary school curriculum
is it it's it's aligned with those
standards but it's not it it it's not
where you go find those standards you
develop curriculum from your academic
standards or and and I think that's good
just to comment on that I mean exactly
right like so the curriculum is not the
academic standards the you have um
academic standards and then the
curriculum is teaching content aligned
to those
standards yeah you can have US History
taught in one school and the curriculum
might may not be the same as it is in
school district B right next door but
the academic
standards have to be reflected in both
of those curricul so give me give me an
example of what that would be Mr chair
where the curriculum's different but the
academic standards the same well we used
to have can I it's helpful I mean like a
simple example is like we've got our
Common Core math and Ela standards um so
those are our academic standards Common
Core Ela standards and Common Core
Mathematics standards but we have a
number of English language arts
curriculum used throughout the state
we've got a number of math curricula
used throughout the state which really
goes to the very heart of you know the
education system which I've shared with
this committee before right so part of
193e one Roman numeral 2 you know school
districts then have the responsibility
and flexibility in developing diverse
educational approaches to instruction
and curriculum tailor to meet their
students needs right so we're telling
them um in statute uh that these are the
academic standards but they are to
implement curriculum that aligns to
those standards but they have a lot of
latitude and flexibility in implementing
a standard that's going to meet the
educational needs of their community and
their students well Mr commissioner I
mean this I think is exactly what I'm
saying that when we when you when you
look at rule 30621
starting on page 19 and let me take it
through Page 20 down towards the bottom
of 20 the local school board shall
distribute instructional uh time to
allow each student to make progression
towards Proficiency in competency in the
following areas so we're in the section
of kindergarten through grade 8 school
curriculum and we're talking about Arts
education including music and visual
arts is in there so why wouldn't that be
an academic standard if an academic
standard is what a student should know
Arts education including music and
visual arts and be able to do in a
course or at each grade level
kindergarten through grade 8 school
curriculum is the um is the section
title for that for rule 21 and I think
something similar for why isn't that an
academic standard so with all due
respect it's a bit of a silly um
construct art is a Content area so if
for example we just said and the limit
of any input to the local districts was
that students should learn have Arts
education program and we didn't provide
any academic standards for that then
that would mean that there would be we
have not weighed in on what kind of
instruction we want the students to be
able to uh understand with respect to
Arts education so this is a Content area
only it's not a
standard so content areas um learning
areas learning areas content areas so so
this goes back to 193 e2a that lists um
all the different content areas
including a couple that were just or the
learning areas because that's the
definition of Statute correct thank you
for correcting me so uh in in e2a and we
recently added well we put personal
financial personal finance literacy and
we juggled around a little bit social
studies we added in yeah so is isn't
that isn't that precisely the area that
the legislature is looking to protect
when it comes to these rules reflecting
on on um on making sure that uh that the
rules for um for for our public schools
are in fact consistent with the um the
these core areas outlined in3 e2a
because the legislature doesn't get into
you know here is all the curriculum
here's the the you know the subject on
you know Martin Luther King and here's
how you're supposed to teach that and
Abraham Lincoln we're not getting into
that in um in law so the academic
standards in statute are sufficiently
high to be to be you know laid out in
193 e2a and that that clearly is what
the what the legislature is talking
about when it talks about academic
standards means what a stu student
should know and be able to do in a
course or at each grade level because
the the law doesn't specify uh curricul
um the law doesn't specify you know how
to you know you know what the deter what
the cutline is for um for proficiency
the law doesn't specify that but it's
clear that the law in in 193 C8 which
establishes this committee 193 e2a for
um uh CND d uh how this committee
actually has a responsibility in the
development and recommendation of rules
prior to going to the board and and that
that responsibility is limited to the
academic
standards that are um that that clearly
are are laid out 193 e2a um uh in
statute and that anything that's going
to be you know jiggling around how um uh
rules that touch on those that I think
it's clear Mr chair that that falls
within the purview of this committee to
to review recommend um subject to our so
so with all due respect I you know I
think if you look at 4 a um it says like
the minimum standard for public school
approval and the areas identified in
paragraph one where are you now Mr
commission I'm 193 e2a okay Roman numer
4 a right and essentially this is where
we Define in adequate education um and
you've defined the stat the legislature
has defined the learning areas of which
these are the learning areas and we have
married the language in these rules to
the statute for the learning areas and
they're they're termed learning areas
these are not termed uh you know
academic standards they're in statute
they're called learning areas academic
standards does show up over ver on to as
you pointed out in C you know the State
Board should not amend any existing
academic standards those acade it's and
just by virtue of the fact that the
statute specifies it it's clear that
this list is not the academic standards
academic standards are something else I
have Arts academic standards in the
framework as represent lad has pointed
out so so so let me
be
30621 was gutted I I'm not proposing
this but let's just say it was
completely hollowed out that didn't
require Child Development learning in
all domains physical sour cognitive
language didn't require direct child
directed experience movement creative
expression remember we're talking about
K8 through here didn't include Arts
education music Visual Arts didn't
include English language arts and
reading didn't include health and
wellness education or phys physical
education or digital literacy or math
I'm literally going down all of the
areas in in
30621 and I think there's a parallel in
30622 physical education dig digital
literacy Math Science Social Studies
including Civics and Holocaust and
genocide education that this could all
be hollowed out by the by the state
board and that wouldn't be subject to
this oversight committee is that what
you're saying I'm not sure I understand
the hypothetical question no no it's
it's it's it's a very clear question if
modification to
30621 is not subject to to this
committee then what what you're saying
is that the State Board could do
whatever it wants with
30621 I'm suggesting that that's not
correct
almost everything in 30621 is actually
directly from statute so it's all yeah
I'm in so this what we did we had there
used to be in the previous rule proposal
there were items that were enumerated in
this list that were not included in
statute and the O that from previous
rule proposals and the OLS attorneys
asked us to remove those because they
were not enumerated in statute yeah and
and and I'm I'm I'm not taking a um a
position opposed to
30621 I'm just trying to understand why
30621 or why any changes to 30621 are
not subject to this committee's
oversight okay let me just reference
back to what we did last year and that
I'm looking at the bill which we had
which was 1107 which dealt with the
curriculum Frameworks but that also
amended the section of law which is RSA
186 col1
and it got down in Roman five and then
we looked at ABC and on down curriculum
is defined there and curriculum means
lessons and academic content taught in
school or in a specific course or
program then D was added that's the
curriculum framework and I can remember
us holding it up because we wanted to
get a real good definition for that it
says curriculum framework means an
organized plan of study that serves as a
guide and reference to what New
Hampshire students should know and be
able to do in a learning area and
identifies the academic standards
aligned with each learning area pursuant
to RSA 193 193 E2
A1A um so the the responsibility for
curriculum and curriculum developments
totally that of the local school
board and instruction as well
but they are required to ensure that
that curriculum that they're adopting
and approving in that school district is
align with the academic standards this
is primarily the reason why this was put
forward because we know that may not in
fact be happening everywhere and if
we're going to have a Statewide
assessment which is built around those
academic standards then we want to make
sure that instruction curriculum and
assessment are all aligned so that we're
assessing what should be taught and so
uh you know I I think we're on the we're
going in the right direction now uh
because I I'm I'm a total believer that
curriculum is a local responsibility
instruction is also how you teach
something it's up to the teacher in the
classroom and the school district we're
in we're in the same page Mr chair what
what with what you're just saying there
um I'm just putting it out that
that that if if in the the rules that
implement the minimum standards for
public school approval
um if they point to um to things that
are academic standards such as such as
um assessment um you know what a student
should know at a grade level or content
areas um uh through curriculum
Frameworks which clearly
Implement a a a curriculum sequence
consistent with academic standards if if
these rules rely or lean up against um
uh the frame the curriculum Frameworks
then then then these rules therefore
incorporate academic standard into them
and what I'm suggesting is that if
if the reliance on on those more
specific academic standards such as
assessment such
as um um a curriculum framework if those
were
removed then then then that would be a
that would be an issue for this or those
were changed then that would be an issue
um
uh a matter for this for this committee
I believe we've even strengthened the
process by taking it from rules and put
putting it in
statute uh so now we're no longer going
to be you um putting all these things in
their individual little groups and
there's it's a shared responsibility of
the state but it's also so we don't Silo
curriculum we don't Silo instruction we
don't Silo assessment they they're
overlapping but there in order for us in
and so that there is some direction that
this state has the academic standards
have be made at the state
level um so so what what does this
committee have responsibility over well
we have responsibility to ensure that
the the Department's not going to change
those learning areas without having
approval from the general
court that that is so I think that's
correct like you are defining what is in
adequate education so you're enumerating
that list and we've had to try we've
tried in these rules to have Fidelity to
that list and then I would point you to
the other statute that you referenced
the State Board of Education should not
amend any academic standard so if we
decide to amend an academic standard um
you know uh shall not approve any new
academic expence without prior review
and recommendations from this
legislative oversight committee so um if
we were to come and say to you we want
to modify the Arts academic standards um
we would come to you for review and
recommendation
um you know we so we would seek we would
deliberately seek your input with
respect to that but that's not the same
as referencing uh you know this
here I think we're conflating two things
okay so so U so basically what I'm
hearing you say is
if
30621 was hollowed out I mean I'm not
suggesting it I'm not suggesting that
that's been done
30621 that that clearly reference things
that are more specific in terms of their
academic nature um to it the curriculum
Frameworks and things like that um if uh
if this was changed wouldn't matter
wouldn't be subject to the um the review
and recommendation of this committee is
that correct again I'm not sure I
understand the question if you want to
try and clarify that uh I so if if uh if
this if this committee were to
eliminate not this committee if um if if
if if a proposed rule was to um
eliminate
um I'm looking at paragraph H in
30621 where it talks about social
studies including Civics number one and
number two Holocaust and genocide
education if um if if you were putting
forth a draft rule that eliminated H
that wouldn't be subject to the review
of this committee is that
right so again I just I I'm prefer not
to play hypothetical we think that this
rule proposal has Fidelity to the law
let me just go reference the statute
e2a part 4 Roman 4 C the State Board
shall not amend any existing academic
standards and shall not approve any new
academic standards without the prior so
amend or approve yeah so again I don't
think that that statute applies here
because we're not talking about academic
standards I think you would be back on
statute Roman numeral 4A as opposed to
where you were um you know and I'm
reading uh you know the general cour
periodical
frequently uh changes made by the board
of of Education to the school approval
standards referring to the list in 193
E21 right so for example and so if we
change that list like say the State
Board of Education came along it says
they want to
include uh you know square dancing as a
part of an adequate education not and
not included as an arts program like the
the the State Board of Education I don't
believe has the ability to add items to
what is required for adequate education
okay no I I appreciate that commissioner
and um but but again going back and I
and I appreciate it's hard to answer
hypothetical questions but but if if if
H was removed from 30621 so the part I
just said social studies including
Civics and Holocaust and genocide
education if that was removed from
30621 how would the framework or the
academic standards then be Tethered to
the the rules for minimum for the
minimum rules for school approval how
are those even even incorporated into
the rules for school approval How could
a school be approved if the academic
standards are floating over here
somewhere without any tether to to um
the rules that are in front of the
proposed rules that are in front of
that's why you have social studies
incorporated into the curriculum through
grade 8 school curriculum there in Ed
30621 social studies is now mentioned
it's a learning area that you must
include in your curriculum in this
school I I get that but if it were if it
outes something that's subject to this
committee's review and recommendation so
representative L I think it's a it's a
it's a I don't think it's a legit it's a
it's a logically flawed analogy in the
sense that even if the State Board of
Education removed that from here and I'm
not sure where we're going with this
conversation truthfully but if they were
to remove that that would not eliminate
the requirement for schools to be
teaching that it would eliminate that
from this rule but it remains social
studies remains in statute you know the
the academic standards you know remains
in statute um you know those
requirements haven't gone away simply
because something has come out of this
rule so I'm not sure what the I don't
I'm not sure where we're going with this
conversation yeah yeah to to me it's all
it's connected and so there's there's
rules that we're looking at in here that
I think relate to clearly to
non-academic areas and and you know you
know temperature inside a building or
something like that I mean I don't know
um but there's there's other rules in
here that clearly lean on on academic
minimum standards and by leaning on an
academic minimum AC an academic standard
that's over here doesn't doesn't that
also incorporate that academic standard
into the rule that's really what I'm
getting at here and I'm not I'm not
suggesting that every rule here is
subject to the the review and
recommendation authority of this
committee but I believe that some of
them are and and I believe that 20 and
21 and 22 at least are and the reason
we've jumped to 21 and 22 is because
they were referred to in
30601 um or something like that yeah so
so I disagree I think we have Fidelity
to the statute in this rule proposal and
so um I understand thank you for
explaining kind of the hypothetical that
your model that you're constructing
there um you know but I think that this
approach that we have taken has Fidelity
to the
statute
chair just in in my thinking if um the
state board was to eliminate h um
they're not eliminating it from statute
it's in statute so um uh I don't think
it's uh going to eliminate social
studies from our classrooms because it
it remains in
statute but you got to remember the
purpose behind what we have in front of
us are these the minimum standards for
public school approval if I'm coming
from the Department I'm going out and
looking at District a here and they have
no social studies being taught in there
and they're not going to get our
approval seeing that it's in these yeah
they're violating basic statute right
but they're also not complying with the
rules for what your curriculum must
include right and and and I I agree with
that Mr chair um but
but the
only so what what you what you the way I
interpret what you what you say is that
is that is that changes to this rule
would be subject to our
recommendation see what if if it's if
it's if in fact we're here to approve
today the minimum standards of public
school approval we're not we're here to
review these in terms of academic
standards uh maybe in another
week when September one the new law goes
into effect where we're incorporating
the oversight committee has the
responsibility for minimum standards
Public School approval it might be a a
different B game because because you're
looking at everything within the minimum
standards for public school approval and
can I just one other comment I want to
make so representative I'm more and more
understanding kind of what you're
talking about here but if if I look at
so I assume you're on page 21 where
you're saying take out social studies as
an example yeah but understand that that
is qualified it it's embedded in one
right and it's embedded in C and so
we're not by this rule we're not telling
them they have to teach social studies
what we're telling them is a local
school board shall distribute
instructional time to allow each student
to make progression towards proficiency
and competencies in the following areas
right so that's not we're not like
eliminating that I mean to to
representative cordell's point is in
eliminating the requirement for social
studies that's in the law you know and
then you know for Elementary grades 1
through eight where no middle school has
been established by vote of the local
school board these are those areas that
we want them Distributing instructional
time so that students are able to make
progress in those areas so that's what
that is saying right if I read the rule
that's what's being referenced there
so rep and cordelli yes isn't this more
um for social States more process
related to the statute and that we're
saying there has to be instructional
time for these content areas in Middle
School um which is reflective of Statute
so it's the process of providing
instructional time yeah it's operational
correct I mean so so that again that's
what this is that's where social studies
is qualified there
so okay so what what you're saying if
I'm if I'm understanding that that that
basically the list of of of the the core
areas the learning areas in 193 e2a uh
for minimum for U as as a as the
definition of an adequate education
those are what and I agree with this
these are what what every public school
um has to offer this breath of thing
doesn't mean that every student has to
take World Language uh because we don't
have graduation a State graduation
requirement World Language some high
schools may have that but um but but a
school a public school would have to
offer the breadth of that so so I I
guess um I'm I'm now thinking that that
since since it's what a school needs to
offer as opposed to what a student um
should learn then then are we are we
saying that that that there's no
coupling of of academic standards to um
to minimum School approval because I I
think if you're if you're if the if the
adequate education is um is saying that
that yes you must offer World Language
but but but it's not required
that we're not actually saying that a
student needs to or or should be able to
means what a student should know and be
able to do in a course or at each grade
level
um you know we're not saying that there
yes I think you're actually referencing
a separate set section of the rules
under um Ed
306 22 is it 22 um and it basically says
uh you know School District shall
develop competencies based on State
academic standards where applicable for
all courses of study school districts
may use State model competencies to
develop minimal competencies so so I
think we're getting there but the
section that you're referencing I'm not
sure
that is where is is applicable to the
conversation that we're having
so I think we all share the same goal
we're trying to help these kids I
appreciate that commissioner um M Mr
chair I um Christine Downing who who
chair Klein had had leaned on
substantially at the board meeting had
if Christine is it very very brief
because I want to just keep this between
that you know right here because we're
trying to get through this front half
today uh Christine go ahead thank you
representative live um totally will be
quick um the only thing I would point
out in that language of K through 8
school curriculum that 21 lead in um is
there is there could be confusion around
the phrase that outlines District
competencies for grades uh 1 through
eight because that phrase itself that
describing phrase it's not clear I think
the rule is intending on saying there is
an elementary school curriculum that
outlines District competencies because
in my conversation with the commissioner
it's always been the state establishment
the State academic standard but we're
leaving the development of competencies
at the district level but the way it
reads one could interpret that it says
is an elementary school curriculum align
to state standards that outline District
competencies it could someone could read
this and say are the state standards
outlining the district competencies I I
I I would caution you about that phras
phrasing because it can open itself um
and the other thing I would just point
out in the high school
conversation is um you do have a little
bit of a disconnect going what in terms
of outlining what an adequate education
is made up in those learning areas
because you got two learning areas in
there um logic and rhetoric and personal
finance literacy that have no State
academic standards so when you have a
leading phrase that says you know the
local board will you know basically
establish a curriculum that aligns to
State Standards what are you going to
tell your high school folks because they
don't have state standards in logic and
rhetoric and personal finance literacy
so you know these are things to think
about in the nuances of the
instumentation and I just want to end
with this one comment lots of
conversation here about the word
curriculum as a practicing curriculum
director I I keep it this simp simp
curriculum means these things it's
everything put together yes State
academic standards are part of our
curriculum process but a curriculum at a
local level does does four things one it
tells us what do we want students to
know and be able to do that our that's
our State academic standards how are we
going to measure that student progress
that goes back to that collection of
evidence conversation you had at the
beginning third is what are we going to
do for Stu for all students are typical
students so they have learning
opportunities and Pathways that support
those first two questions and then the
fourth question which is where we now
build in our intervention systems is
what do we do for those students who
aren't making that progress and how do
we interv a full curriculum written at a
local level which is why we have that
curriculum Frameworks now which is going
to get at some more of that Beyond just
what the State academic standards do for
us that's what a real curriculum
implemented at a school level needes so
I just wanted to share from a
practitioner's point of view um and just
some of the wording in here you know the
friendly amendment I would offer to this
leadin statement might be something like
the local school board shell require
that in each school there's an
elementary school curriculum that
outlines District competencies for grade
1 through eight comma align to State
academic standards so it's very clear
where the competencies are coming from
because that's always been a point of
confusion in the minimum School approval
standards
is who's making the competencies is it
the state or is it the local um that's
all I would I would mention on
that further disc
discussion okay um I I'd like to keep
moving along here a little bit I I I had
a question though on page
seven um and I might as well get on with
my question right
here um it's on page seven item
f for schools with grades k through
eight the offering of one or more World
languages including
are you now saying that we have to have
8 so I believe then there's another spot
and I'm going to wait for Julie to come
back up that it isn't a requirement but
we do know that some of our schools are
offering World languages in K8 and so
we're providing to trying to provide
Guidance with respect to that offering
this the K World
languages okay um yes so pre in the
previous um in the previous or the
current rule I should say there was
language that said if a school is going
to offer it through K through 8 they
have to have a policy that outlines what
that looks like I get that I get that um
and so if they're not offering it then
they also say that they're they're not
required to offer it through so you're
not saying you need it okay and we don't
have theth it's a choice exactly okay
um um on on page six I'm rolling back a
little bit because we jumped up to the
other end there uh but on the bottom
page six has
30621 basic learning standards
include is
that see we use the word standards a
lot and is it confusing or is are we
really trying to say basic teaching in
practice and practices
include these following things like
homework
um promoting students from grade level
to grade level you know the you know
whether you're going to have AP courses
or you know career related courses you
know all that is is part of the teaching
and the implementation practices which
we include with then conveying
instruction uh and curriculum you can
take that word practice back to the um
you know the stateboard of Education
yeah because learning standards okay now
what kind of what is a learning standard
is it all these things which are you
know boy I wish we gave more homework in
some of our schools we used to have
policies on that for every grade level
so many more minutes are tacked on that
that's exactly what this is is the
policy that the school board has to have
the outline lines what their policy is
on homework what their policy on is
promoting because this is in the policy
section right yeah yeah yeah get
it
righty okay we're we're messing around
here up in front of these first Pages as
long as we're there I'd like to go to my
favorite topic Career Technical
30616 okay um item C right in the middle
of the page CT Cooperative agreement
shall require the sending and the
receiving school districts to coordinate
calendars and schedules to maximize
students access to CTE programming
pursuing to 830 I think it'd be great if
you also put in and RSA
188e colon 1- a Roman 3 which
specifically States what those Regional
agreements have to have we put this in
the law several uh 13042 is actually the
rules that specifically talk about the
regional career agreements that went
through the process last year so it
details I know this may be duplicative
but it does do any harm
to say it again yeah
um and and and then going down jumping
down to
D I'm getting into things like
maintenance of effort but that's a
different topic for today every public
high school student shall have access to
programs at the regional CTE Center
subject to attainment and of
prerequisites and space availability
within the program in the CTE Center and
the sending school budget restriction
and the sending School District budget
restrictions we passed in
HB one and two an additional $4 million
for tuition and
transportation we did it in a separate
Grant seeing that we didn't want to harm
the maintenance of agreement that we had
I can remember that discussion with the
Senate but um I this is just Rick glad
speaking right now um I understand space
Avail availability that's an issue which
we have to do with some of our Capital
monies prerequisites I understand that
um but the latter part within the
program in CT say and the sending school
budget
restrictions this is one of the reasons
why we only have 17% of our kids in CTS
because the cost and scheduling in all
those other
variables we want more kids there we
want to double this number so is that
last part of the sentence necessary in
the sending school budget restrictions
if they're if we're restricting then
it's up the legislator to do something
about
that right I mean I'm not I I do
understand the issue relative to um
transportation budget restrictions that
may or may not happen um with respect to
the $4 million we've had open grants for
um reimbursement of tuition for CTE um
only at the last time I checked was
probably about a month or so ago about
600,000 of that had been applied for um
so because the other has to be used
first before you can apply for
well this was any time you had it was it
was retroactive if you had an upside
down circumstance is the way that you
could get reimbursed for that so um but
there may be I I can't speak to whether
there may be other budget restrictions
that would affect um you know that so it
has nothing to do academic standards
it's just a flag that I've caught here
that's a rick lad type thing seeing I've
always been very strong in CT and and
the last part under G part one at the
bottom of the page there it says the
multi-level Career Technical education
as defined in Ed 306 in sequential
fashion based on curriculum specific
competencies endorsed by CTE and
Business Leaders I'm a little confused
and I I I think I may have some
somewhere along the way Frank about
Business Leaders what what what are yeah
so the way that the CTE program works is
for every one of our programs we have an
industry advisory Council um and so we
do have for each of our programs we
approve um specific specific program
competencies for each of the various
things whether it's Automotive or
welding or business or whatever it might
be um and those are approved both by the
either CTE centers as well as by the
industry advisory Council who provides
input and approves those competencies
for each program so a lot of these
competencies we which we have in centers
right now are based upon industry
standard correct they mostly they are
driven by industry standards because
each program is also required to have um
you know an IRC and Industry recognized
credential and so we're trying to align
the programs to help the students
achieve that you know independently
recognize uh you know professional
credential when they come through the
program so would it be wise to say
instead of Business Leaders but and
aligned with industry standard or
something language so we want to align
with those
standards Which business is yelling for
us to
attain and and teach in diesel mechanics
two does talk about National Industry
standards yeah I know it and then also
in E prerequisites shall be directly
related to a student ability to
successfully complete the CT program of
core technical competencies vetted by
business and industry and post-secondary
institutions so um you know we so we're
weigh we're leaning heavily and we do
rely heavily on our uh industry Partners
to make sure that the programming that
we're setting up um is what the industry
is looking for
that's all I had on that page on 15 I
did have one other issue
there uh four uh where it says imple
implements third-party assessments as
recognized and designated by the
department um when we have like at the
center up in Berlin when somebody comes
in that's uh a welder the the assessment
is based upon the National Standard um
so are you approving that or as
recognized
and designate or approved by the CTE
Center itself so this is um dealing
specifically with industry recognized
credentials and we've got a rubric for
how those are evaluated um there have
been instances where we have programs
that don't have an industry recognized
credential per se um and yet we still do
believe that there is a demand for that
in the space and so when that happens
what H we do is we basically put
together our own industry recognized
credential um by talking to Employers in
the area in the state and and vetting
the program standards and competencies
with them saying hey kids who come
through this program is this a program
that you would be you know want to hire
a kid out of um and then what we
basically do is have those industries
that and those business specific
businesses that have approved that to
put their logo on a certificate so that
that student when they graduate would
earn that certificate and they would be
able to take that we're trying to give
them something portable they could take
that to a job interview and say like hey
I went graduated from a CTE Center and
the five you know uh you know Machining
shops in this area have all approved the
program that I went through and said
that it's a it's a legitimate program
and that I've learned the core and the
important you know aspects of of
Machining so so the department is
engaging in in recognizing that machine
shop or correct so we'll work with them
trying to create I don't have an
industry recognized credential we'll go
create one to make sure because again it
could be something that's emerging you
know e bikes are coming out there's not
an industry industry around ebikes right
but there's a lot of people who want
technicians who are able to work on that
type of technology in the growing space
but until the industry catches up with
it um we want to make sure that we can
continue to give students something
that's
portable does the committee have any any
other areas which we want to look at
when you're talking about go ahead on
page 17 when you're talking about local
assessment and
accountability and on on the botom
bottom of the page there you have a uh
one and you struck out two you talk
about local standard
s um provides for ongoing assessment of
District competencies and graduation
required requirements through the use of
local assessments that are aligned with
State okay State andw I didn't see State
good I yes go ahead I could just ask
again about U Back to page 15 um at D on
the bottom uh talks about um
confidentiality of information and it
references uh Ed uh
1119 that would 1119 would refer to
statutory language in that regard I
assume yes Ed 1119 is actually special
education so it refers to um
okay are there and looking at
at this further here is there any other
areas that maybe a a Committee Member
here wants to look at um has there on
page 30 has there been any
changes um or considerations given by
the
department de I want to talk about
mathematics just for a second um of
requiring we require now
three credits or three course you know
three years and one year embedded math
would be embedded in something approved
by the local board have we thought about
when it comes to mathematics going from
three to four credits at
all so I can say that there was
substantive conversation about that and
in fact if you look on the next page um
which is the chart that was proposed by
initial in the initial proposal yeah um
they had increased at to 3.5 um and then
added including algebraic Concepts and
at least a half Credit in statistics and
data analysis because the board
perceived that that was an area of
deficiency um through the public input
process uh that was reduced back down to
three um you know credits but there was
certainly a lot of conversation around
whether or not we needed to increase
that and and where that manifests itself
we see in the post-secondary world where
students perhaps have completed their um
you know their math credits by the time
they're Junior so they maybe are not
taking any math credits as a senior
other than in an in an embedded type of
a way and um as a result of that when
they get to their postsecondary
opportunities be that the community
college system or other postsecondary uh
sometimes they're in need of remedial
types of uh courses because they of the
the length of time between those math
experiences they don't like to call them
remedial cours anymore I know they in
betting coquis on specific skill Co yeah
requisite um and when I was over at any
HTI this last week and working with Math
teachers from out the state on the math
learning communities program there was a
lot of chatter about four four
credits in mathematics to you know try
to you know move the bubble a little bit
in terms of uh when kids do go to
postsecondary education they're they're
equipped with some of the I mean
relative to these tables there's quite a
bit of conversation yeah um at the State
Board level as well as lots of public
input that was all considered as they
went through the
process
okay is there any other discussion we
have all my comments I've
addressed
um representative Cornell anything
else are you with me on the CTE stuff
there Patty great thank you okay uh
represent
luno uh sure on um on page
22 going into
30622 uh the rule uh with respect to
High School curriculum credits and
co-curricular programs uh where the um
the the the word course has been
um deleted um several times and in
particular
in
B where we talk about um so on page 22
uh
30622 school districts shall develop
District competencies as opposed to
course competencies based on State
academic standards where applicable uh
for all courses of study school
districts may use State model
competencies to develop minimum District
competencies so where where the word
course has has been um been removed
there uh does that
um and and you know and it it's clearly
used to modify the word competencies and
we also have academic standards in that
um relate to um to essentially amending
for example if you took the word
academic standards out of there would uh
would would that rule be would a change
to that rule be um you know be in the in
the perview of this committee to review
and
recommend just saying if you took the
out not sure I understand yeah yeah yeah
so I'm I'm just saying is is that rule
306 22b so this this what what I'm
really trying to get at commissioner is
is what this committee's responsibility
is and if we're just here to provide
some feedback and take it or leave it
these are our comments as as a
legislative committee then great there's
no Authority here but if this committee
has authority to review and recommend
I'm trying to understand where that
Authority lies because so far I haven't
I I I I haven't heard that this
committee has any authority to review
and recommend we're just here as
legislators providing comment based on
what we think should happen take it or
leave it um trying to understand if
there's if there's any Authority that
this committee has so in in 30622 b um
because it references specifically the
word academic standards does this
committee have authority to review and
recommend and I'm not saying we wouldn't
recommend that change I'm not saying
that but do we have an authority do we
have a responsibility to review and
recommend
30622 B well so what I I would first
start out and just say you know
irrespective of whether or not you have
authority to do this I think um that the
department has been very and the State
Board of Education has been very
responsive we we've met with you
multiple times taking your input as
public input and as input into this
process uh and you will see many of the
recommendations that were recommended by
this uh body we we took that seriously
and we have Incorporated many of those
changes um I I still the hypothetical
I'm not I'm not sure so how would you
read be I'm I'm just trying to get away
from you know is is this committee a
work group or is this committee have
have review and recommendation Authority
because I read the law it says we have
review and recommendation Authority and
that we've got responsibility in terms
of process and sequence in rule approval
and and if this is just a work session
Then I then I you know it doesn't say
work session in the law uh it says
review and recommend and I'm just trying
to understand if there's any
responsibility that this committee has
in the in the process in sequence of
rule approval yeah so I would uh
reference you to again 193 E2 a uh sub
you know for Sub C the State Board of
Education shall not amend any existing
academic standard and shall not approve
any new academic standards without the
prior review and recommendation of the
legislative oversight committee so I
think that that very precisely talks
about your role with respect to academic
standards um and then I had previously
referenced as well in 4 a where it says
uh change changes to the enumerated list
of the content areas for an adequate
education it says changes made by the
State Board of Education to the school
approval standards through rulemaking
effective date of this section shall not
be included within the standards until
they constitute an opportunity for
delivering inadequate Education Without
prior adoption which would require the
entire general
court so those are the two things that I
would point to I didn't is did I miss
something you were referring to courses
taking out of there and I didn't know if
that was to your question it was it was
a change that that has been proposed by
the department in a rule that um that
clearly talks about academic standards
so so you know so I just sort of picked
up on on on a rule that uses the word
academic standards and a change an
amendment an a you know it says shall
not approve shall uh shall not amend or
approve any new academic standards these
would not be new academic standards so
okay so even a rule that refers to
academic standards isn't subject to this
they would not they are not academic
this is not an academic standard oh okay
and even a rule that that refers to an
academic standard wouldn't would would
therefore not be subject to this
committee again I believe that we've
followed the appropriate process and are
have Fidelity to the statute in terms of
the rul making process that we followed
here okay thank
you the s perspective you've gotten from
the jail car attorneys we have worked
very closely with them in this
process yes rep and Cordell uh yes I was
just looking on page
33 um
3625 um is this in relation to um RSA
uh this rule predates the statute of
innovation rule so there's always been a
process where if there was um something
that they needed alternative approval
for this would be the process for it
okay
um and I guess I'll just point out there
is a separate rule that has been adopted
by the legislature for the Innovation
well with the introduction of the
legislation we put forth where the
academic standards will be reflected in
the Frameworks that's where they are and
and you're referencing the areas of
learning Within These
306s and we've also addressed the issue
that we were concerned initially with
definitions and those have been all been
corrected to reference the
rsas um I guess I'm I'm at the point
where on on this portion of 306 is I I
have nothing further to really offer you
at this time other than you
know it seems like you're
you're we've got this thing in hand
especially with the the the house bill
which we put forward now we also have on
11:07 but we also have the other Bill
coming forward where you know change
coming so it' be interesting to see how
that pans out that's one that gives this
study committee the authority to make
recommendation on on all the minimum
standards um I kind of look forward to
it you know I know I know you probably
don't look forward us doing that but I
I'm really been uh you know I see some
districts where you have to have how
many credits to get out of school 24 or
so or 22 27 yeah yeah okay wow and and
some that are offering 20 to get out and
those graduation competencies developed
at the local level so those those areas
which I'd like to dig into sometime
here thank you yeah are there any other
comments before we you know take the
leash off I just wanted to get over to
was you are 25 I think so so I'm over on
state board oh yeah establish of State
academic standards okay state board
establishment of State academic
standards so
um and I apologize Mr chair because I'm
working from both the the old and the
new the old and the new exactly so I'm
looking at the side by side that uh that
Jennifer for uh
prepared uh based on the February draft
and so I'm on page 43 of the side by
side do you do you have the side by side
no I don't have the side by side with me
today so want you to read what we we've
got there so the the the side by side is
is um is helpful uh because the side by
side shows how how 306 26 state board
establishment of State academic
standards has
removed um references to Ed
30631 relative to Art
education 37 relative to English
language arts um 40 relative to health
education 41 relative to physical
education 42 relative to digital
literacy 43 relative to math 45 relative
to science 46 relative to social studies
program 49 relative to Holocaust and
genocide
education um and that's at the um um uh
for grades 1 through eight where no
middle school has been established and
then it continues on in a very similar
vein um with those same uh references
for middle school
and and so those references have been
removed so these are the cross
references that are clearly um pointing
to academic standards so is do does this
this goes right back to the same and
sorry to the um you know Groundhog Day
here but but is Ed
30626 subject to the review and
recommendation of this committee given
the given the content I think you're
referring to an old number because the
current 30626
doesn't remove anything it's all new
language yeah see that's hard to it's
you know it's hard to tell because we
don't have the the difference between uh
between this and the current rules it's
only this and the earlier draft right
and and so
26 so 26
is all right so so this is
now ed20
30620 I mean I'm I'm now looking at at
the side by side used to be 30626 it's
now
30620 and so kindergarten um grade 8 U
and
it's it if it's changed again I I I
so yeah so we already talked about two
so I'm not trying to I'm not trying to
uh go there again but um but what I
didn't see when we talked about it
earlier when we talked about 21 earlier
was um because I think I was referring
to the today's handout and let me just
today's handout
on
3621 doesn't
show that that that for element you know
for instance
um Jesus is heart I'm sorry it's painful
um that the that the that the current
21 or wherever it is um in current law I
mean in current rules for Elementary
grades 1 through eight where no middle
school has been established by vote of
the local school board um the school B
shall adopt for each School a local
um time schedule will specifies
distribution of instructional time among
the following learning areas to be
taught in grades 1-8 at all learning
levels in the school um Ed 30631 37404
142 all the things that I just talked
about so all of those cross references
have been eliminated um Mr chair is this
subject are our cross references
specific rule cross references to
academic standards is this subject to um
this
recommendation and it's cross
referencing you say two academic
standards that are where that are in
rules 31
30631 through 49 there and it may not be
yeah so again I'm more point back to the
statute as well the State Board should
not amend an existing academic standard
so this is not amending any existing if
it refers if it if it's if if if
essentially the rule is providing a
tether to an academic stand standard and
that tether is cut um then then that's
not amending the academic standards it's
just simply setting the academic
standard free from implementation we
have not amended any academic standard
no I understand that but if you if you
set an academic standard free from
implementation if the implementation is
the local school board shall adopt for
each School a local time schedule which
specifies the distribution of
instructional time among the following
learning areas to be taught in grades 1
through eight at all learning levels in
the school and it lists all of these
academic standards and you're not
changing the academic standards you're
just changing the fact you're just
changing the implementation of those
academic standards at the local level
that that's not actually modifying an
academic standard is that what I'm
hearing you say so what I'm telling you
is that we've not modified any academic
standards in this rule you're just
you're just untethering it from
implementation so that they're just
floating over here not we've not
modified any academic I understand so so
did so would those academic standards
still apply um in the the rule that I'm
talking about so 306 out 21 yeah so
academic standards continue to apply and
we've got academic standards that the
State Board of Education has adopted and
those are on our website how do they
continue to apply um in
30621 uh because you're required I mean
if I go back to the section in G where
it talks about the requirement to have
academic standards that align to the
state standards that then models
competencies so there's a number of
other places in this Rule Body where
those are uh
interconnected no could you point out
where standards 31 through 49 the
30631 through 49 and there's some
numbers missing in there could you talk
about how could you show us in the
minimum standards for school approval
the proposed minimum standards for
school approval where those academic
standards are being are being referenced
that a school a school that does not
Implement those academic standards would
fail to meet the requirement for minimum
School approval isn't this why we just
did 11:07 though the academic standards
are now located in the curriculum
Frameworks and we yeah we mentioned
curriculum here but your curriculum has
to be aligned with those academic
standards I'm just I'm just trying to
see where it where it where where it's
Tethered to the rules for
implementation I mean
you do you see what I'm saying Mr chair
this the implementation is done through
your instruction and your adopted
curriculum in the school right so but
your your academic standard though is
immersed into that
curriculum and and in practices through
your instruction are there as well when
you talk about homework or some of this
other areas um so I guess I would ask
are you really looking to see the
academic
standards everything that's in those
Frameworks service guidelines and there
and I've asked the question many times
before where do I find the academic
standards I've asked that for years here
asked it last year on my website on the
and and it's I've been told the academic
standards are located in the um
basically curriculum Frameworks for each
of those learning areas all right so do
we need to duplicate that in 306 if it's
already referenced over there in the
Frameworks so let so all right so let me
put the question out there because these
this is beyond the first half so
30631 relative to an Arts education is
that an academic standard so what I
would tell you is school districts and
ref refered your question we we looked
at this section before it's in
30622 uh school districts shall
develop uh District competencies based
on uh State academic standards where
applicable for all courses of study
school districts may use State model
competencies uh to develop minimum
District
competencies so so thank you um so
is what what what we're in right now is
is I think we were back to
30621 which the the earlier draft had
eliminated and I didn't you know sorry
for not picking up earlier cuz it wasn't
contained and what was handed out today
the earlier draft had eliminated from
30621 had eliminated a reference to
30631 relative to an Arts education so
my question to you commissioner is is
30631 an academic standard so what I
would tell you is that that is referring
to academic standards that are on the
Department's website at this point is
that a yes that 30631 is an academic
standard I don't have those with me so
I'm not prepared to speak to those okay
so all right so just for the purpose of
because I believe there's a separate
rule proposal the back half is coming
and we're not here to talk to those at
this I understand I understand just for
the purpose of of discussion though if
if that is an academic standard would
eliminating the cross reference to that
academic standard be um from from
the minimum St minimum standards for
school approval would would that mean
that a school a public school could be
approved without providing an Arts
education so if it were an academic
standard again pointing back to the
statute the State Board of Education
shall not amend any existing academic
standards and this proposal in front of
you does not amend any existing academic
standard right we're talking past each
other commissioner what what I'm talking
about is when you take an academic
standard and it's Tethered to an
implementation so the implementation in
the existing um rule 30621 if that's
still the same number um is the local
school board shall adopt for each School
a local time schedule which specifies
the district distribution of
instructional time among the following
learning areas to be taught in grades
1-8 at all learning levels um in the
school and this is where it talks about
30631 relative to an Arts relative to an
Arts education 37 relative to English
language arts if all of those things are
are are taken
out how are those minimum how are those
academic standards then incorporated
into the standards for M the minimum
standards for school
approval so I'll talk process here for a
moment so the reason those numbers were
taken out is because so we we split this
into two proposals there were a lot of
there was a lot of ring because we added
some sections we removed some sections
there were sections that were reserved
so the numbering as you can see as we've
been going through it has changed
significantly and that includes the
numbers in the other half that we
haven't yet addressed those numbers are
going to change and regardless of the
content in those areas they are still
part of the rules and so they have to be
followed right they haven't gone away
they're still live there are actual
rules that are in place but you just
don't know what um but what I would tell
you is that changing a reference to an
academic standards it does not
constitute a as enumerated in statute an
amendment to an existing standard right
changing changing a reference to a
standard is not changing a standard okay
no no fair fair fair enough um I'm
wondering what the what the obviously
what the legislative intent was you know
when the when the legislature created
193 e2a Roman for um C and D but but
regardless of that what what you just
read off um uh with respect to academic
standards is actually the language um in
the law so what I want to get at is is
if um
if you take out all those cross
references 30631 relative to Arts
education 37 relative to language arts
does a local school board need to um
need to provide uh a local time schedule
it specifies the distribution of
instructional time among the following
learning years do does the Schoolboard
have to do anything to provide
instruction in those in for those
academic standards he's on 21 do they
need to be compliant with the academic
standards in order to be approved
question wasy understand find the place
where you are there so again it says in
30621 right so the rule as adopted will
state that the local school board shall
distribute instructional time to allow
each student to make progression toward
proficiency and competencies in the
following areas and it enumerates those
areas so that is a requirement that a
local school distribute their time to be
able to offer that instr ruction and
then I would point you again back to
over on page 22 where it says school
districts shall develop competencies
based on State academic standards right
so all of those standards that have been
adopted were applicable for all courses
of study can I just ask question so
there that's how see just so finalize
this question so it says right there
that school districts shall develop
competencies based on State academic
standards where applicable for all
courses of study so if art is a course
of study then you shall have you shall
uh have competencies that uh are based
on State academic
standards Cornell yes on on page 20
where it says the local school board
shall distribute instructional time I'm
just is there a definition for
instructional time is that a
class is it's
defined I I missed it instruction is is
defined so instructional time is also
all around page
so um so so I I I appreciate that and I
and and thank um representative Cornell
for that for that question with regards
to instructional time does that
instructional time have to be consistent
with with the academic standards in each
of these areas for and I'm looking at on
on the bottom of page 20 from today's
handout where you've got
c1a for instance Arts education
including music and visual arts it so
what is the question it
is so
c1a requires the local Schoolboard sh
distribute instructional time to allow
each student to make a progression
towards Proficiency in competencies in
the following areas right and so a is
Arts education including music and
visual arts so is that does that
instruction instructional time that the
school board
has to provide is that is that
consistent with I how does that have to
be consistent with an academic standard
yes so the academic standards are not
defining how much instructional time
they are not connected to the
instructional
time that that changed you know we we
once had uh in all the New England
states we had specific minutes per week
where you must teach
history or you must teach
science um then we came along with
thematic reading and everything else and
they're saying well I'm teaching Social
Studies by way of this thematic reading
program in my reading time so I'm Co
covering two subjects at one time less
minutes we got away from that uh what we
are primarily interested in the issue of
time is how much that time is engaged
time time in which instructions actually
occurring or is it time that's just well
the clock started at 9:00 it's now 9:45
we've had our time well how much is that
really engage time maybe 20 minutes 25
minutes out of that whole time so that's
an instructional methodology that it it
comes underneath a different baileywick
which you know it's it's a supervisory
issue it's a a a a a teacher issue to
use time wisely um I mean and it's also
a flexibility issue for a local District
to make determinations in terms of the
allocation of their time because they're
going to have different cohorts of
student and what we're saying is that we
want to allocate the time so that
students make progression towards
proficiency um and so that may look
different in different for different
students for different schools and would
that proficiency have to be um towards
the academic standard listed out in
30631 for an Arts education program they
would be proficient in the competencies
as is enumerated there that the local
school district has adopted remember
that was that thing that I just read you
out of B on the following page right so
so what what what they adopt does does
that have to be compliant with an
academic with a academic standard so
what it says is that they have to be
based on the academics the state's
academic standards but again
representative luno and it seems like
we're going around in circles here a bit
the we don't perceive that that is an
amendment to an existing academic
standards again uh so I'll just continue
to focus on that yeah so where where um
I was reading the statute
which statute were you reading the one
that we continue to refer to in 193c it
says the State Board shall not amend any
existing academic
standards okay so right right so even
even where an academic standard is is
being used to uh to guide a or to to um
to to require a school board to do
something um providing uh instructional
time to to meet an academic standard
where that acade academic standard has
no longer being referenced in that rule
um how does the school board know what
to do number one and number two how does
the State Board of Education know if a
um no if a school board I'm sorry no if
a school should be approved again so you
have referenced their using the State
academic standards I certainly hope that
they are using those standards because
we want them to do that that is the
purpose
uh use of a standard would not
constitute an amendment to a
standard right even when it's taken out
of implement I mean I I I honestly I'm
you know my background is engineering so
when you don't refer to a to a technical
reference eliminating that technical
reference is the same thing as changing
that Technic so the technical reference
because it untethers from the from the
implementation I mean so I'm I'm sorry
if um if if I'm looking at this process
is in a much more rigorous way than um
than maybe um what the what the how the
department interprets it but I have a
hard time believing that the
legislature would would would feel good
with with modifying rules amending rules
uh to uh to relieve School boards from
following academic standards so that
would be just to be clear like and I
want to make sure this is on the record
that's an incorrect characterization and
I will read again to you uh 30622 B
School District shall develop
competencies based on State academic
standards were applicable for all
courses of study the State Board the
public who has provided extensive input
into these rules has not uh you know
untethered the education for these
students it is clear in this rule
proposal
are you there I'm done
good uh any further comments from the
committee at this time I want to thank
you very much for coming today and
helping us out with this um now this is
the front side when when's the backside
up
okay thank you how many versions are you
going to
have there go okay thank you very much
have a great afternoon
okay already as the committee right now
so on on this front
side you know other than what we've
discussed here I don't have any other
make yeah I I you know I I I see the
role as this committee is not being sort
of like a recommendation work group I
see it as as as having responsibility
and review and and uh uh and
recommendation Authority uh as part of
the process and I'm I'm
um in terms of the academic standards I
could make a recommendation right now
saying I you know I don't see the
academic standards being changed I see
them
continuing um and so that's part two and
that yeah and then we look at part two
and and see where we are with that and
uh then we will have of course more uh
ability to look at all minimum standards
in that part too yeah no I I I I
appreciate that but um but from a from a
um from a you know sort of a process
standpoint where where or actually from
a um from a I mean I'm making a
technical argument here that when when a
rule references another rule um that and
and that that cross reference to another
rule is in fact a technical standard
then that becomes incorporated into the
rule that was using it and and I I I I
certainly understand that that in the
areas that we talked about no if if Ed
30631 relative in arts education is and
I'm looking at it right here so so it's
I don't know one and a quarter P one you
know one one and a half one and a quter
one and a half pages long that you would
just cross reference it you wouldn't
actually copy and paste all those words
uh into it you'd cross reference it and
and and the reason it was cross
referenced because it was actually
saying the School Board needs to do
something with this with this academ to
follow this academic standard and by by
taking out the cross reference you're
essentially taking out the language from
that cross reference um that was
incorporated by reference into the rule
and and and I I think it's a I think
it's a very fair way of of of both you
know making um uh making it easier what
we're trying to do and also be being
being rigorous getting academic
standards located in one place getting
them clarified uh is important I can
remember going back to July 1 2015 when
I sat on jail car
and there was a proposed rule change of
course the department missed the
deadline and so
36.
311 didn't go forward and that was more
than one and a half pages I believe when
you talking about art and the health and
some of those other areas it became
almost three pages and it was turning
into the 306 is becoming the academic
standards and very confusing and I think
that confusion has now been eliminated
through what we did what we need to do
now is make sure those curriculum
Frameworks are updated make sure the
curriculum Frameworks reflect those
academic standards that we we are
wanting because I think that's the key
to having successful curriculum
instruction in our local schools if we
have those all aligned and aligned with
our Statewide assessment we want that
assessment assessing what we're
supposedly teaching and so I I think
we're on the right right track here it's
going to take a little bit to get this
thing all in line but I think we're
moving it very very quickly here and uh
I mean in terms of what we are directing
we we we believe academic standards are
extremely important as a state and and
that's why we need to look at those
Frameworks which are the academic
standards I'd like to see some clarity
within the Frameworks as far as this the
the specific academic standards and
because the rest of it's guidelines in
terms of how you might teach economics
or whatever and and what you might
incorporate into it in terms of content
and skills but uh I I I'm I'm good with
the 306 is the way we are because I
don't think we're cutting anything out I
think we're referencing it in the proper
space
now yeah I disagree on that
but it's okay to disagree yeah we'll
walk out of here shaking hands still
yeah no worries about that okay good
enough so it is lunch time and we have
another meeting starting up in another
hour uh some of us so um with that we'll
close this this uh education study
committee and uh we look forward to the
the second